* Anhaltendes Donnern *
* Rauschen, Prasseln *
* Sphärischer Klang *
1999 drangen die Lawinen in den Alpen
bis in die Dörfer vor.
Das hatten die Einheimischen
seit einem halben Jahrhundert
nicht mehr erlebt -
die meisten von ihnen noch nie.
Wir hatten grosses Glück,
weil wir die Strasse
rechtzeitig gesperrt
und die Leute evakuiert haben.
Im Nachhinein kann man sagen:
Wir haben alles richtig gemacht,
alles gut gemacht,
aber es war wirklich
eine Aktion nach Gefühl.
Es kamen Tausende Lawinen
innerhalb weniger Tage.
Einzelne erreichten im Talgrund Orte,
wo niemand sie erwartet hätte.
Im Walliser Dorf Evolene
begrub eine Lawine
neun Menschen unter sich.
Kurz bevor es
in Evolene passiert ist,
sind die grossen Lawinen im Goms,
im Lötschental
und in Leukerbad niedergegangen.
Wir haben gesagt: "Endlich
löst sich der Berg ein wenig."
Wir haben gespürt, dass
die ganze Spannung am Berg kommt.
"Jetzt entleert sich der Berg."
Wir hätten nie an Evolene gedacht.
Der ganze Alpenraum war betroffen,
vom italienischen Aostatal
über die Schweiz
bis ins österreichische Galtür.
Zum ersten Mal
waren nicht nur Einheimische,
sondern vorwiegend Touristen
unter den Opfern.
Wir möchten unser Mitgefühl
und unsere Anteilnahme ...
... zum Ausdruck bringen.
Das war ein Wechselbad der Gefühle:
auf der einen Seite
sehr viele Vorverurteilungen,
die gänzlich unberechtigt waren,
auf der anderen Seite
ein hohes Mass an Unterstützung,
ein hohes Mass an Solidarität.
Es war ein schicksalhafter Moment.
Die einen waren
mit ihrem Auto zu früh unterwegs,
die anderen zu spät.
In Evolene wurden fünf Feriengäste,
vier Franzosen und ein Schweizer,
in ihrem Chalet begraben.
Das letzte Foto vom kleinen Edgar
und seiner Mutter Delphine.
2 1/2 Std. später
waren die beiden tot.
Der Franzose Jean-Louis Combes
verlor seine ganze Familie.
Martine, meine Frau.
Delphine, meine Tochter.
Edgar, mein Enkel.
Und Eric, mein Schwiegersohn.
Die Sicherheitsverantwortlichen
von Evolene
wurden wegen Fahrlässigkeit angeklagt
und verurteilt.
Das war in der Schweiz
noch nie vorgekommen.
Ich habe
ein ziemlich ruhiges Gewissen.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
* Langgezogene,
eindringliche Klänge *
Seit dem historischen Lawinenwinter
ist in Evolene viel geschehen.
Heute halten Stahlnetze den Schnee
in den Hängen des Torrent du Brequet.
Hier hat sich die todbringende Lawine
am 21. Februar 1999 gelöst.
Sie riss ein bewohntes
sowie elf evakuierte
oder leer stehende Chalets mit sich
und verschüttete zwei Strassen.
Nichts konnte sie aufhalten.
Auch diese Schlucht nicht.
Bis dahin hatten die Bergbewohner
solche extrem grossen Lawinen
stets als Schicksal hingenommen.
Nun wurde in Evolene erstmals
die Frage nach der Schuld gestellt.
Wie schwer sich die Leute von Evolene
mit dieser Frage tun,
lässt die unscheinbare
und namenlose Gedenktafel
für die Lawinenopfer erahnen.
Für die Gemeindepräsidentin
von Evolene
ist der Lawinenwinter 1999
fern und nah zugleich.
Im Februar 1999
war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Ich war daheim mit meiner Familie.
Plötzlich wurde es schwarz.
Wir hatten keine Elektrizität mehr.
Wir wussten nicht, was passiert war.
Wir warteten,
aber das Licht kam nicht zurück.
Erst am anderen Morgen hörten wir
die schreckliche Nachricht.
Wir kannten einige der Opfer.
Später an dem Tag brachten
unsere Eltern uns zu dem Ort,
wo die Lawine gekommen war.
Wir hatten es im Fernsehen gesehen,
aber wir konnten nicht glauben,
dass es bei uns passiert war.
Zwei Tage nach dem Unglück
kamen Bagger zum Einsatz.
Dennoch gab Jean-Louis Combe
die Hoffnung nicht auf,
dass seine Familie noch lebte.
Es sind solche Bilder,
die das Dorf in der Val d'Herens
jahrelang verfolgt haben.
In den Jahren darauf
hatten viele Leute Zweifel.
Sie informierten sich,
bevor sie herkamen.
Es war schwierig, aus Evolene wieder
eine Winterdestination zu machen.
Noch vor wenigen Jahren,
wenn man auf Google Evolene eingab,
kam man direkt
auf das tragische Ereignis.
Sicher,
es gehört zu unserer Geschichte,
aber das darf nicht alles sein
zu Evolene im Winter.
Auch im österreichischen Galtür
sind die Hänge heute gut
gegen Lawinen gesichert.
Auch hier
erinnert eine Tafel an die Toten.
Im Gegensatz zu Evolene
sind alle mit Namen aufgeführt.
Die Grieskogellawine
zerstörte einen ganzen Dorfteil
und verschüttete 31 Menschen.
Wie in Evolene
sahen die Verantwortlichen auch hier
die Katastrophe nicht kommen.
Noch nie war eine so grosse Lawine
von diesem Hang abgegangen.
Auch dieses Dorf war nach dem Unglück
nicht mehr dasselbe.
Anton Mattle war schon damals
Bürgermeister von Galtür.
Das Ereignis hat unsere
Dorfgemeinschaft durchaus verändert.
Gerade die ersten Jahre danach
waren Jahre,
in denen wir unwahrscheinlich stark
zusammenhielten.
Wir arbeiteten gemeinsam an Zielen,
wir schauten gemeinsam,
dass wir dieses Ereignis
überwinden konnten.
Es hat das Dorf natürlich auch
in seinem Aussehen stark verändert.
Es gibt im Dorf
neue Lawinenschutzmauern
und im Dorf wurde auch
dieses spezielle Gebäude errichtet,
das Alpinarium,
das in einer Schutzmauer
integriert ist.
Trotz der 17 Toten,
die es in der Schweiz gegeben hat,
reden die ehemaligen
Sicherheitsverantwortlichen
von einer erfolgreichen Bewältigung
des Lawinenwinters 1999.
So auch Charly Wuilloud,
der damalige Monsieur Catastrophe
im Kanton Wallis.
Es war
eine unglaubliche Naturgewalt.
Wir wussten schon,
dass die Natur stark ist,
aber mit diesem Ausmass
hatten wir nicht gerechnet.
Und ...
Für mich war es
eine sehr traurige Zeit,
wegen des Falls von Evolene,
wo wir zwölf Tote hatten.
Aber sonst war es
unglaublich reichhaltig.
Der Lawinenwinter hat uns gezeigt,
dass wir
mit der Berechnung der Lawinenzonen
gar nicht so falsch gelegen haben.
Das war ein Erfolg.
Die Leute
glaubten wieder mehr an uns.
Abgesehen von
den tragischen Ereignissen in Evolene
gab es für den obersten
Lawinenschützer im Kanton Wallis
keine wirklichen Überraschungen.
Die Lawinen kamen dort runter,
wo er sie erwartet hatte.
Wir hatten 1999 im Wallis
850 Lawinen.
Nur sechs davon flossen über
die von uns berechneten Grenzen.
Wir mussten damals ziemlich schnell
80 Strassen schliessen
und fast alle blauen Zonen
evakuieren.
Das war natürlich schon ein Erfolg.
Am Ende muss man trotzdem sagen,
150 Gebäude wurden völlig
und 145 teilweise zerstört.
Darin befand sich niemand mehr.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Unglaubliches Glück hatte
der junge Bergführer Peter Schwitter,
und mit ihm
das ganze Walliser Bergdorf Blatten.
Hier ging die Gratlawine nieder.
Es war die grösste Lawine
im gesamten Alpenraum.
Es mutet wie ein Wunder an,
dass es keine Toten gegeben hat.
Der Moment, der mich
am stärksten beeindruckt hat,
war, als ich hier stand,
an diesem Ort,
und zwar genau dann,
als die Lawine sich löste.
Wir befanden uns wegen
eines medizinischen Notfalls hier,
zusammen mit einem Kollegen
von der Rettung.
Punkt 16.57 Uhr
hörten wir ein "Wumm"-Geräusch.
Das hat man deutlich gehört.
Dann hatten wir das Gefühl,
1'000 Lokomotiven oder Güterwagen
würden auf uns zukommen.
Wegen des Nebels und des Schnees
sahen wir nichts.
Erst in der letzten Sekunden
sahen wir sie wie eine Faust
durch den Nebel kommen.
Ich rief dem Kollegen nur noch zu:
"Renn, so schnell du kannst!"
Wir warfen uns
hinter die nächste Hausmauer
und konnten nur noch beten.
Die Gratlawine löste sich
auf einer Höhe von 3'000 m.
Sie war 4 km breit,
die höchsten Anrissstellen
bis zu 8 m hoch.
Wir hatten damals keine Mittel,
um etwas zu sichern oder zu messen -
keine Messstationen, nichts.
Die Lawine riss 45 Gebäude
mit sich in die Tiefe.
Dass es keine Toten gab,
war der mustergültigen Evakuierung
durch den Neuling Peter Schwitter
zu verdanken.
Die Gemeinde Blatten hatte damals
noch keinen Lawinendienst.
1999 hatten nicht alle Gemeinden
Lawinendienste.
Ich war damals Chef der
Bergrettungsstation Blatten Belalp.
Deswegen wurde ich von
der Gemeindepräsidentin aufgeboten,
mich darum zu kümmern.
Um diese Situation.
Durch die Erkenntnisse,
die die Gratlawine brachte,
hat man eigentlich gesehen, dass wir
einen Lawinendienst brauchten,
dass etwas passieren musste.
Man wusste natürlich,
dass auch bauliche Massnahmen
nötig sein würden.
Wir mussten die Gratlawine
in den Griff kriegen,
denn ein Ereignis wie 1999 könnte
in die falsche Richtung laufen.
Es könnte natürlich auch
fatal enden.
Nach den Lawinenniedergängen
war Charly Wuilloud
öfter unterwegs als je zuvor.
Dort, wo die grossen Lawinen
gekommen waren,
wünschten die Menschen nun
Schutzmassnahmen.
Das Beeindruckende ist,
wie nah sie
den Gebäuden gekommen sind
und wie sehr sie
die Bevölkerung verängstigt haben.
Die Leute
brauchten dringend Schutz.
Selbst wenn dieser
nur psychologisch ist,
müssen wir sofort
etwas unternehmen.
In den Gomser Gemeinden
Biel und Selkingen
wurde Charly Wuilloud
mit Ungeduld erwartet.
Nach dem Niedergang der Lawine
fühlten sich die Leute bedroht.
Der Gemeindepräsident von Selkingen
hatte Haus und Werkstatt verloren.
Wir hatten ein Riesenglück,
dass die Lawine hier aufgehört hat.
Und hätte sie sich
weiter oben nicht geteilt,
wäre also nicht ein Teil nach Biel
und nach Selkingen geflossen,
hätte sie das getroffene Dorf
sicher zur Hälfte ausgelöscht.
Bei den Schneemassen
und bei der Feuchtigkeit im Schnee,
hätte es für Selkingen oder Biel
düster ausgesehen.
Die Bieligertal-Lawine
weckte Erinnerungen
an die Tragödie von 1827.
Damals waren 52 Menschen unter
den Schneemassen begraben worden.
Auch wenn es diesmal
glimpflich ausgegangen war,
musste nun ein Schutz her.
So wie es jetzt aussieht,
würde ich sagen ...
Ja.
- Schon etwas tun.
Etwas tun, unbedingt.
Das war 1827 ...
172 Jahre ist es her.
Da ist die letzte gekommen
und hat Selkingen und Biel getrennt.
Und ... Dass man jetzt etwas tun
muss, sehe ich schon ein.
Denn jetzt, wo der Wald weg ist,
kommen die Lawinen noch schneller.
Was mich sehr beschäftigt hat,
war eine Familie in der Grafschaft.
Die Frau sagte mir am nächsten Tag:
"Wenn ihr nicht etwas
zu unserem Schutz macht,
gehen wir nach Andermatt.
Mein Mann arbeitet bei der Armee."
Fünf Leute wären aus dem Goms
weggezogen. Das wäre schade gewesen.
Die Sorge
um die Sicherheit der Dörfer
liess ein altes Projekt aufleben:
den Bau zweier Dämme.
Wenn wir das Dorf schützen wollen,
gibt es vermutlich nur eines:
die Dämme bauen.
Da wären wir natürlich
komplett im Damm drin.
Dann müssen wir natürlich weg,
was für uns Wahnsinn ist.
Ja, was denken Sie?
Das da ... Das ist hart.
Ich schlafe
seit zwei, drei Nächten nicht mehr.
Wenn man so lange da ist
und etwas eigenes hat,
und dann geht das weg ...
Es ist schon in Ordnung, wenn es
anderswo wieder aufgebaut wird,
aber das ist doch nicht dasselbe.
Ja nun, sehen wir mal weiter.
Schliesslich ist das mein Eigentum,
und ich ziehe nicht aus.
Ich sage noch einmal:
Eher verbrenne ich es -
und ich bleibe drin.
Dann brenne ich auch.
Im Sommer 1999 waren die Sicher-
heitsverantwortlichen des Kantons
und der Gemeinde Evolene oft
gemeinsam im Lawinengebiet unterwegs.
Andre Georges war da bereits seit
20 Jahren Chef des Lawinendienstes.
Die Dinge haben sich verändert.
Es ist vielen klar geworden,
dass es Lawinenzonen braucht -
so, wie sie übrigens
existiert haben.
Aber alle haben sie
als zu streng kritisiert.
Nun wird klar, dass man
die Ausnahmefälle ernst nehmen muss,
nur in den richtigen Zonen
bauen darf und vorsichtig sein muss.
Es braucht ein solches Ereignis.
Es macht allen bewusst,
was Sache ist.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Im Tal unten,
wo wir all die Toten hatten ...
Niemals hätte ich mir
das vorstellen können.
Niemand von uns
hätte sich vorstellen können,
dass die Lawine
so weit runter kommen würde.
Sie war nie
über den Fels hinaus gegangen.
Es übertraf alle Vorhersagen.
Das hat mich etwas erleichtert.
Die Frage,
ob es sich bei den tödlichen Lawinen
um Schicksal oder Schuld handelte,
mussten sich auch die
Verantwortlichen von Galtür stellen.
Im Alpinarium zeigt ein Film,
was vor 20 Jahren geschehen ist.
(Filmton) 330'000 t Schnee
rasen mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von 350 km/h auf Galtür zu.
* Anhaltendes, tiefes Rumpeln *
* Krachen *
Ob man das Lawinenereignis
heute mit damaligen Mitteln
erkennen würde ...
Das glaube ich nicht.
Es gab keinen historischen Hinweis
in einer Gemeinde,
die seit 1'000
Jahren an dieser Stelle existiert.
Es gab einfach keinen Hinweis,
dass aus diesem Bereich
zwei dermassen grosse Lawinen
abgehen könnten.
Jetzt wissen wir es.
Mattles Einschätzung
wird auch von den Gutachtern
des Schweizer Instituts für Schnee-
und Lawinenforschung SLF geteilt.
(Filmton) Für die Wissenschaftler
war die Katastrophe von Galtür
ein Mysterium.
Schon bald nach dem Unglück
reisten Lawinenexperten des SLF
ins Paznauntal.
Sechs Monate lang untersuchten die
Forscher in akribischer Detailarbeit
die Verkettung
unglücklicher Umstände,
die zu dem verheerenden
Lawinenunglück führte.
Noch dazu
waren es gerade auch die Fachleute,
die sich dieses Ereignis
nicht vorstellen konnten.
Die haben uns danach auch in Schutz
genommen und uns auch verteidigt.
Sie haben uns dann natürlich auch
gerade diesen ersten Meter unseres
Weges ganz wertvoll begleitet.
In Selkingen
beendete der Gemeindepräsident
im Laufe des Sommers 1999
den Wiederaufbau seines Hauses.
Zugleich trieb er
das Projekt der Lawinendämme voran.
Die Zeit drängte.
Noch immer
war die Angst vor der Lawine gross.
Gestützt auf
eine rudimentäre Fotomontage
bewilligten die beiden Gemeinden
die Dämme.
Es ist immer besser, sofort
eine falsche Entscheidung zu treffen
als eine richtige Entscheidung,
die zu spät kommt.
Damit muss auch ich leben.
Aber die Leute hier, meine Leute
in Selkingen, haben Verständnis.
Es sind sicher Minderheiten, die ...
... die ausscheren.
Teilweise
kann man das auch verstehen.
Einige trifft es schon
besonders hart.
Im Herbst
kamen dann die ersten Bagger.
Es ist eine Schande.
Sie machen alles kaputt.
Die ganze Gegend da draussen
geht zuschanden.
Ich will nur das Bild sehen,
wenn sie fertig sind.
Das will ich sehen.
Das ist doch verrückt.
Ja nun.
Dieser Graben bringt ihnen kein
Glück, das kann ich Ihnen sagen.
Das Projekt war gigantisch.
Die Maschinen blieben
ganze vier Jahre in den Dörfern.
Wie ist die Stimmung im Dorf?
Hundsmiserabel. Das muss ich
schon sagen. Hundsmiserabel.
Die Maschinen
verschoben 150'000 m3 Erde.
Die Lawine
hatte gleich viel Schnee gebracht.
Der Gemeindepräsident von Selkingen
war am Ziel, auch persönlich.
Sein Haus war nun durch eine Wand
aus armiertem Beton gesichert.
Und doch: Vom anfänglichen
Zusammenhalt im Dorf,
von der Hilfsbereitschaft
blieb nicht viel übrig.
V.a. für die Leute, die jetzt sehen,
wie gross das Bauwerk wird,
ist das sicher fast ein Schock.
Vorher hat's einfach
friedlich ausgesehen,
aber es ist doch eine massive Sache.
Aber sie haben sich vielleicht
auch nicht die Mühe gemacht,
sich die Pläne anzusehen.
Ich kann es mir auch nicht erklären.
Die Information wäre da gewesen,
wenn man sie genutzt
und in Anspruch genommen hätte.
Weit weg, in der Normandie,
hatte Jean-Louis Combes
ungleich Schwereres zu verarbeiten.
Man kann nicht ständig sagen,
es gehe einem schlecht.
Die Leute erwarten etwas anderes
und wenden sich ab.
Am Anfang weint man vor den anderen,
aber mit der Zeit lernt man,
dass man die Tränen
für sich behalten muss.
Für ihn war der Verlust
seiner Familie nicht Schicksal.
Er ist selbst Richter.
Mit der Einschätzung
des Walliser Untersuchungsrichters
war er nicht einverstanden.
Für ihn war die Lawine vorhersehbar.
Auch wenn ich Momente
grosser Ermutigung verspüre,
denke ich, dass es eine Art
moralische Pflicht ist,
nicht locker zu lassen.
Er vertiefte sich in die Geschichte
der Lawinenniedergänge von Evolene.
Daraufhin reichte er seine Klage ein.
Es gab bereits 1977
eine Lawine am Torrent du Brequet,
die bis an
den Fuss des Felsens reichte,
also wenige Meter
vom Chalet entfernt.
Mein Problem ist,
25 Jahre später nachzuweisen,
ob die Gemeindebehörden die nötigen
Vorkehrungen getroffen haben,
um die Häuser in den Gefahrenzonen
vor diesen Lawinen zu schützen.
Mit Jean-Louis Combes' Klage
begann eine jahrelange juristische
Auseinandersetzung um die Frage:
Schicksal oder Schuld?
Charly Wuilloud begleitete
den Angeklagten zu jeder Verhandlung.
Für ihn ist das Urteil
bis heute unverständlich.
Ich habe erlebt, wie er
unter dem Urteil leiden musste.
Er sagt fast nichts.
Er ist ein wortkarger Mann -
ein echter Bergler.
Aber er leidet darunter,
dass er ständig
wegen einer Sache angeklagt ist,
an der er nicht schuld ist.
Diese Klage hat dazu geführt,
dass Unwahrheiten verbreitet wurden.
Es ist wohl
ein Zeichen unserer Zeit,
dass man
einen Schuldigen finden muss.
Es hiess, man habe die Leute
an Orten bauen lassen,
wo man nicht sollte.
Aber der Bauherr, Theodoloz,
war kein Fremder,
sondern einer aus Evolene.
Jeder in Evolene hätte dort gebaut.
Die Gemeinde Evolene liess als
eine der ersten Gemeinden der Schweiz
eine Gefahrenkarte erstellen.
1973 sah diese
am Ort des Lawinenniedergangs so aus:
Rot bedeutet höchste Lawinengefahr -
Bauen ist nicht erlaubt.
In der blauen Zone
ist die Gefahr geringer
und das Bauen erlaubt,
vorausgesetzt, die Häuser werden mit
einer armierten Betonwand verstärkt.
wurde der Gefahrenplan revidiert.
Die rote Zone war nun kleiner,
die blaue grösser.
Das ermöglichte den Bau
des Chalets Theodoloz.
Dieses stand nun
mitten in der blauen Zone
und nicht mehr
an der Grenze zur roten.
1993 wiederholte sich das Prozedere.
Noch mehr Rot wurde zu Blau
und damit Lawinenland
zu lukrativem Bauland.
Nach dem Unglück stellte sich heraus:
Das Chalet Theodoloz war ohne
die obligatorische Schutzmauer
aus armiertem Beton errichtet worden.
Das Chalet dort oben
hätte vielleicht widerstanden,
wenn es aus Beton gewesen wäre.
Die Lawine kam nicht schnell,
denn der Schnee war schwer -
mit viel Masse, aber verlangsamt.
Also, mit Beton ...
Man hätte nur das Erdgeschoss
aus Beton bauen müssen.
Das Holz darüber
hätte es mitgerissen.
Die Leute waren ja unten
im Wohnzimmer, als die Lawine kam.
Aber von diesen Dingen
ist nie gesprochen worden.
Das ist doch erstaunlich.
Man hat bloss dem Architekten
die Frage gestellt.
Es war verjährt.
- Das war's.
Biel-Selkingen
im dritten Jahr des Dammbaus.
Die Angst vor der Lawine
war längst dem Ärger
über den Lärm und den Staub gewichen.
Es tut wirklich weh,
wenn man das sieht.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, dass
es kein anderes Projekt gegeben hat,
dass das ganze Tal
verschandelt werden muss.
Wir haben Einsprachen gemacht,
aber die Herren haben sich keine
Zeit genommen, sich das anzusehen -
sie haben es
unter den Tisch gewischt.
Was können wir jetzt noch tun?
Ich wünsche auf jeden Fall allen,
die am Graben beteiligt sind,
viel Glück.
Nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Im Winter 2002
mussten die Andereggens ausziehen.
Herr Andereggen.
- Ja?
Wenn Sie den Hang hochblicken,
was denken Sie?
Katastrophe.
Es ist eine Katastrophe.
Das denke ich. Ja.
Andereggens Haus
war zum Abbruch bereit.
Über die Höhe der Entschädigung
war ein zermürbender Streit
ausgebrochen.
So ist die Natur, und die Natur ...
Ich bin wegen der Natur
und der Situation nicht wütend.
Wirklich nicht. Das ist die Natur,
und es passiert überall.
Überall müssen Menschen wegziehen
und ihr Leben anders gestalten.
Das ist ganz klar.
Die Situation der Menschen
ist das Problem,
nicht ... nicht ...
nicht das Wetter usw.
Ich habe nie geflucht
wegen der Lawine.
Die ist halt mal gekommen.
Das ist hier in den Bergen ...
Es ist nicht unbedingt normal,
aber das muss man fast
als Normalität sehen.
Das ist nun mal so.
Aber die Menschen?
Die Menschen, ja. Ja.
* Langsame, nachdenkliche Musik *
Seit der Damm steht,
sind die Dörfer zwar
sicherer geworden, aber auch kälter.
Schon am frühen Nachmittag
wirft der grosse Bieliger Damm
lange Schatten auf das Dorf.
Der Gemeindepräsident von Selkingen
weist jede Kritik von sich.
Die 52 Toten sind nun mal da.
Die kann man nicht wegstreichen.
Es müsste noch eine Katastrophe
geben ... Was ich nicht hoffe.
Aber für die Besserwisser
wäre es vielleicht gut,
wenn die Lawine noch mal
bis zum heiligen St. Anton käme.
Ich weiss es nicht, aber ...
Es war ja alles da, aber
man hat es vielleicht verdrängt,
ist mit den Bauzonen und allem
etwas lockerer umgegangen.
Das sind vielleicht
Fingerzeige der Natur.
Ich sage immer:
"Die Natur gibt es uns,
aber sie will es auch zurückhaben."
Sie lässt uns nicht schalten
und walten, wie es uns passt.
Das müssen wir einfach einsehen.
Die jährliche Prozession zum Gedenken
an die Lawinentoten von 1827
konnten die Dämme
nicht zum Verschwinden bringen.
Jetzt, wo Sie die Lawinendämme haben,
müssen Sie doch
keine Prozession mehr machen.
Was denn, denken Sie,
das Leben geht ohne Glauben?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Doch, das müssen ...
Diese Prozession ist schön.
Nein, die behalten wir schon.
Alte Bräuche muss man erhalten,
fertig, Schluss.
Trotz der Dämme?
Ja, ja. Ach!
Ach, dass Sie immer denken,
die Dämme wären ein Schutz.
Das ist ein Schutz, fertig.
Wenn der Herrgott sagt,
er kommt, dann kommt er,
und wenn nicht,
dann kommt er nicht, fertig.
Die Lawine von Evolene
löste sich in einer Höhe
von knapp 3'000 m als Staublawine.
In den tieferen Lagen
riss sie nassen Schnee mit sich.
Dass sie durch die tiefe Schlucht
und sogar über den Felsen
hinausdringen würde,
dafür gab es in Evolene,
ähnlich wie in Galtür,
keine gesicherten
historischen Hinweise.
In Evolene existierte jedoch
eine gültige Gefahrenkarte.
Diese stützte sich nicht
auf historische Lawinenereignisse,
sondern war durch eine
Computersimulation berechnet worden.
Für die Einschätzung
des Gerichtsgutachtens
war sie dennoch entscheidend.
Wenn ich daran denke,
dass bereits in den 70er-Jahren
Fachleute auf die Lawinengefahr
hingewiesen haben
und dass sie in den 90er-Jahren
bestätigt worden ist,
dann muss ich jetzt ganz klar sagen:
Die Lawine war vorhersehbar.
Die Gefahrenkarte
verdeutlicht diese Einschätzung.
Unvorhersehbar
war gemäss Gutachtern
lediglich das Ausmass der Lawine.
Sie floss über die rote
und die blaue Zone hinaus.
Dort, wo die Lawine gekommen ist,
ist das Bauen heute verboten.
Die Gerichtsverhandlungen
dauerten Jahre.
Angeklagt waren
der Gemeindepräsident von Evolene
sowie der Chef
des Lawinendienstes der Gemeinde.
Anwesend im Gerichtssaal
war auch Jean-Louis Combes.
Es ist umso schmerzhafter,
weil es der sechste Jahrestag
des Unglücks ist.
Seit 2'186 Tagen
warte ich auf diesen Prozess.
Zur Anklage
kamen nicht die verjährten Vergehen
wie etwa
die fehlende Schutzmauer des Chalets,
sondern lediglich das Verhalten
der beiden Verantwortlichen
am 21. Februar 1999.
Gemäss der Gerichtsakten brach Andre
Georges an diesem Morgen früh auf.
Er erstellte ein Schneeprofil
und kam zum Schluss,
dass in Evolene
sehr grosse Lawinengefahr bestand -
Gefahrenstufe 5, d.h. höchste Gefahr.
Ja, ich gab Stufe 5 aus.
Es war total aussergewöhnlich.
Regen und nasser Schnee
bis auf 2'000 m.
Ich dachte,
er würde die Lawine bremsen.
Es war unvorstellbar,
dass es so gross werden würde.
Ich hatte in den oberen Lagen
einige Chalets evakuiert.
Es war unvorhersehbar,
dass die Lawine
bis zum Talgrund kommen würde.
Nachdem er die Gefahr
festgestellt hatte,
traf Georges sich
mit dem Gemeindepräsidenten.
Dieser segnete seine Massnahmen ab.
Für den Talgrund,
wo sich die Kantonsstrasse
und das Chalet Theodoloz befanden,
beschlossen sie keine Massnahmen.
(Heimgartner) Der Rettungschef
hatte für den besagten Tag
allerhöchste Lawinengefahr
ausgerufen, also Stufe 5.
Und er hätte entsprechende
Massnahmen einleiten müssen,
die in diesem Fall gelten.
- Was wäre das gewesen?
Die Sperrung der Strasse und die
Evakuierung der gefährdeten Gebiete.
Gegen diese Massnahmen
sprachen zwei gewichtige Gründe:
das Fehlen historischer Hinweise
und die Daten der Messstationen
in und um Evolene.
Aufgrund der Schneemengen,
die wir hatten,
gab es keinen Grund,
die Strasse zu schliessen.
Wenn wir hier oben mal
22-25 cm Schnee bekamen,
war das fast das Maximum -
vielleicht 40 cm.
Das ist nicht sehr viel
im Vergleich zum restlichen Kanton.
Es regnete oben.
Der Regen hätte den Schnee
stabilisieren müssen,
aber das tat er nicht.
Die Unterlage war nicht so gut.
Dass eine so grosse Masse
in diesem Volumen aus dem Couloir
und bis zur Strasse fliessen konnte,
kann ich mir
heute noch nicht vorstellen.
Die Einwohner von Evolene
kannten sich mit Lawinen aus.
Sie mussten immer wieder
Verschüttete bergen.
Allerdings waren in Gebäuden
seit über 200 Jahren
keine Menschen
von Lawinen getötet worden.
Daher war die Ratlosigkeit gross,
als am 21. Februar
die Nachricht
von verschütteten Häusern eintraf.
Man hätte
ein Konzept entwerfen müssen,
wer wann was unternimmt -
z.B. für die Strassensperrung,
die Evakuierung,
wer die Leute
aus welchen Häusern holt,
wo im Dorf sie hingebracht werden.
Im Normalfall werden
diese Massnahmen geplant und geübt.
In Evolene war das nicht der Fall.
Wegen dieser Unterlassung
wurden die beiden Verantwortlichen
der mehrfachen
fahrlässigen Tötung beschuldigt
und zu bedingten Gefängnisstrafen
und einer Geldbusse verurteilt.
Möchten Sie dem Gemeindepräsident von
Evolene und Andre Gorges etwas sagen?
Ich habe Ihnen nichts zu sagen.
Au revoir.
Es gab einige Jahrestage seit 1999.
Jedes Jahr am 21. Februar
erinnert man sich in zwei Sätzen
an die Verurteilung.
Es gibt Leute, die nicht wissen,
was sich ereignet hat.
Wenn man sagt,
dass der Gemeindepräsident
und der Sicherheitschef
verurteilt worden sind,
erfasst das nicht das ganze Problem.
Aber man muss damit leben.
Mein Gewissen ist ziemlich ruhig,
das ist gut.
Der Lawinenschutz hat vom Urteil
von Evolene profitiert.
Gefahrenkarten können seither
nicht mehr übergangen werden.
Das ändert nichts daran, dass
das Urteil bei vielen Einheimischen,
insbesondere den Sicherheits-
verantwortlichen im Berggebiet
auf Unverständnis gestossen ist.
Viele sehen ihre beiden Kollegen
als Sündenböcke.
Die Sicherheitsverantwortlichen
von damals,
die in der Situation entscheiden
mussten, sind natürlich schon ...
Ja, das hat
sehr grosse Emotionen geweckt.
Was waren die Argumente?
Man wusste einfach
plötzlich nicht mehr,
ob man überhaupt gedeckt ist,
wenn mal etwas passiert.
Wer trägt am Ende wirklich
die Verantwortung?
Wofür wird man verurteilt
oder nicht?
Was können sie einem vorwerfen?
Ab welcher Lawinenstufe
muss man eigentlich sperren -
oder sollte man sperren?
All diese Fragen
standen plötzlich im Raum
und wurden z.T. nicht beantwortet.
So entstand
eine grosse Unsicherheit.
Im österreichischen Galtür hat sich
die Schuldfrage nicht gestellt.
Entsprechend leichter ist dort die
Verarbeitung der Tragödie gefallen.
Im Alpinarium
pflegt man die Erinnerung
in einem eigens dafür
eingerichteten Gedenkraum.
Wenn ich jetzt
an den Winter 1999 zurückdenke
und mir die Frage stelle:
"Was war denn die grösste Leistung
unseres Dorfes?",
so war es nicht der Wiederaufbau,
und es war auch nicht
der Bau des Alpinariums,
sondern die Freundschaft
zu den Hinterbliebenen
der Opfer von Februar 1999.
Und es ist schon etwas Besonderes,
wenn die Hinterbliebenen
wieder nach Galtür kommen
und bei denselben Vermietern wohnen,
aber auch zu mir
aufs Gemeindeamt kommen
und wir gemeinsam lachen
und einen Schnaps trinken können.
Das ist eine gute Bewältigung.
Evolene ist heute weit,
was den Lawinenschutz angeht.
Nach anfänglichem Zögern
kommen auch die Feriengäste wieder.
Was die Bewältigung
der Tragödie von damals angeht,
bleibt dagegen noch viel zu tun.
Es wird
eine grosse Gedenkmesse geben.
Aufseiten der Gemeinde
sind wir dabei,
die Familien der Opfer zu befragen,
denn es ist sehr schwierig,
in dem Zusammenhang zu wissen,
was von gutem und
was von schlechtem Geschmack ist.
Es ist sehr kompliziert,
aber wir müssen etwas tun.
Und dafür
müssen wir die betroffenen Familien
auf unserer Seite haben
und nicht gegen uns.
Auch aus Biel-Selkingen
gibt es verhalten gute Nachrichten.
Berta Hauser hat ihr Haus
vor einigen Jahren
doch freiwillig verlassen.
Seit die Dämme stehen, haben sich
einige neue Familien niedergelassen -
allerdings nur in Selkingen.
Alt Gemeindepräsident Markus Walter
freut sich darüber.
Es ist ihm eine späte Genugtuung
und rechtfertigt den grossen Eingriff
in die Landschaft.
Den Preis für die Sicherheit
bezahlt er gerne.
Mein Haus ist geschützt.
Man sagt immer, es habe Minderwert,
aber hier könnte man sagen:
"Muss man jetzt nicht
einen Mehrwert bezahlen?"
Das ist ja auch immer
die Diskussion:
Wenn man etwas schützt,
hat es dann nur den Minderwert
oder kriegt es da nicht einen
Mehrwert, weil es bleiben kann?
Es gibt vielleicht
2 Std. weniger Sonne.
Ich kann mir nicht anmassen,
zu sagen:
"Das ist richtig
oder jenes ist richtig."
Aber man könnte sagen,
es habe einen Mehrwert.
Ich schlafe wieder gut.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Das sagst du jetzt, weil du
auf dieser Seite des Damms wohnen.
Ja, ich lebe
auf der Sonnenseite des Damms.
Alles hat ja zwei Seiten.
Aber zwei Enden hat nur die Wurst.
Das wird auch hier so bleiben.
Es wird nie ein Ende haben.
Man kann es nie allen Recht machen,
und das wäre auch gar nicht gut.
Auf der Bieler Seite
nimmt die Bevölkerung fortlaufend ab.
Die Andereggens sind noch da.
Sie haben ihr neues Haus
in sicherer Distanz zum Damm gebaut.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
die Dämme wären letzten Endes,
wenn man es aus heutiger Sicht
ansieht, nicht nötig gewesen.
Nie im Leben.
Aber wir hatten keine andere Wahl,
als Ja zu sagen.
Die Verwaltung
hätte uns fertiggemacht.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass wir das getan haben.
Man sieht sie fast nicht mehr.
Und wir wissen, es ist ein Schutz,
den gewisse Leute sehen,
aber die meisten tun es nicht mehr.
Er ist gut versteckt.
Derartige grosse Ereignisse
werden keine Dörfer mehr zerstören,
solange wir solche Schutzmassnahmen
treffen können.
Es war kostspielig,
aber wir konnten ein paar Leute
im Goms behalten.
Charly Wuilloud
geniesst seinen Ruhestand.
Er konnte in seinen letzten Jahren
als Sicherheitsverantwortlicher
im Wallis sämtliche Gebiete,
in denen 1999 Lawinen die Menschen
bedroht und getötet hatten,
mit Schutzmassnahmen sichern.
Heute gäbe es wahrscheinlich
kein zweites Evolene.
Heute haben wir die Gefahrenkarte
viel besser im Griff,
und die Sicherheitsverantwortlichen
sind viel besser ausgebildet.
Man kennt auch die Standorte,
wo sich gewisse Fälle
ereignen könnten.
Aber einen Gletscherabsturz
können wir nicht vorhersagen.
Von Bondo
wusste man auch nichts im Voraus.
Solche Fälle gibt es immer.
Aber eine grosse Lawine
in Wohnsiedlungen
werden wir vermutlich
nicht mehr erleben.
Das haben wir im Griff?
Ich vermute es - oder ich hoffe es.
Auch die Gratlawine
oberhalb von Blatten ist gezähmt.
20 Jahre lang hat Peter Schwitter,
der zum regionalen
Lawinenspezialisten aufgestiegen ist,
mit ihr gerungen.
(Funkspruch) Hier, 4 m.
Das ist schon gewaltig.
Erst hat er versucht,
sie mit Sprengstoff zu zähmen.
Der Einsatz des Helikopters
zum Sprengen
hat sich nach dem Lawinenwinter 1999
allmählich durchgesetzt,
wenn auch nur zögerlich.
* Dumpfes Rauschen *
Zur Bekämpfung der Gratlawine
gab es jedoch keine Alternative.
Als wir
aus dem Helikopter schossen,
hatten wir zwei oder drei
brandgefährliche Situationen.
Der Helikopter ist zwar
ein super Instrument zum Schiessen,
aber er kann nur
bei gutem Wetter fliegen.
Deshalb mussten wir immer warten,
bis die Wetterlage vorbei war,
bis die Schneefälle
und der Sturm vorbei waren.
Erst als es ruhiger wurde,
konnten wir starten und schiessen.
Das bedeutete nach
drei oder vier Tagen Schneefall,
dass wir enorme Schneemassen
abschiessen mussten.
Das löste dann z.T. Lawinen aus,
die wieder fast bis
zur Kantonsstrasse flossen.
Das ist in meinen Augen ...
Ich wollte und konnte das
nicht mehr verantworten.
Nach 1999 herrschte eine
ganz klare Angst vor dem Schiessen.
Da waren die Negativbeispiele
Leukerbad, Evolene und überall.
Das war auch verständlich.
Es war nicht einfach.
Anfangs war es wirklich ...
... nicht einfach, zu entscheiden,
was das Beste war.
In den folgenden Jahren testete
Peter Schwitter immer neue Methoden,
um die Lawinen zu entschärfen.
(Funkspruch, Mann) Peter, zünden!
- Fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins ...
... und knall!
Super. Super Lawine.
Heute ist das Sprengen von Lawinen
der schweizweite Standard
im Lawinenschutz.
Heute haben wir Messstationen,
Mittel, um Lawinen abzuschiessen,
Möglichkeiten,
mit dem Heli zu arbeiten.
Alles Mögliche, um uns selbstständig
zu organisieren und zu entscheiden.
Es ist natürlich schon
viel einfacher und besser als 1999.
Seit 2009 haben wir Gasexanlagen,
die über den ganzen Hang verteilt
sind - 13 Zündrohre insgesamt.
So können wir den ganzen Hang
portionenweise abschiessen.
Abschiessen
und mit lichtempfindlichen Kameras
aus sicherer Distanz überwachen,
ob die Sprengung
erfolgreich gewesen ist.
Der letzte Schrei
ist die Überwachung per Radar.
Das Lawinenradar
hat einen grossen Vorteil.
Es erlaubt uns, zu jeder Tageszeit
und bei jedem Wetter zu schiessen.
Es hängt nicht von der Sicht ab.
Es nimmt die Lawinen
auch bei Nebel, Wind oder Sturm auf.
Das erleichtert uns die Arbeit,
denn wir können Lawinen
auch in den Randzeiten schiessen,
wenn wir weniger Probleme
mit Kantonsstrassen haben
und weniger Personen
auf der Piste sind.
Nach jeder Sprengung
kontrolliert Peter Schwitter,
wie viel Schnee sich gelöst hat.
Dabei inspiziert er auch
seine 13 Kanonen.
Hier sieht man diejenigen gut,
die wir das letzte Mal
geschossen haben.
Da hat die Windrichtung
nicht gestimmt.
Und hier hat sie gestimmt.
Hier war genau Nordwest.
(Funk) Das andere Rohr
ist eingeschneit.
Ja, richtig.
Das hier wurde zugeweht.
Hier sieht man schön die Wechten.
Ein sehr schöner Anriss.
Alles ist geräumt,
bis auf den Boden.
Die Kanone hier hat immer
eine sensationelle Wirkung.
Sie hat immer ...
- Sie steht am richtigen Ort.
Die Anlagen stehen eigentlich super.
Peter Schwitter setzt grosse Hoffnung
auf diese Technik.
Mit ihrer Hilfe
will er sowohl das Schicksal
als auch die Schuld eliminieren.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass wir mit den heutigen Mitteln
diese Situationen
in Zukunft besser meistern können.
Der letzte Winter
hat es ja schon gezeigt.
Wir hatten enorme Schneemassen.
Ich musste allein die Gratlawine
zehnmal schiessen.
Und es waren sieben- oder achtmal
wirklich grosse Lawinen.
Wir konnten eigentlich den ganzen
Winter problemlos überbrücken,
ohne grosse Massnahmen
wie Evakuierungen treffen zu müssen.
Das zeigt: Mit diesen Mitteln,
wenn man sie richtig einsetzt
und die richtigen Leute dran sind,
die das richtig handhaben ...
Ich bin überzeugt, dass wir das ...
... in den Griff bekommen können.
Es ist ein wenig ...
Es ist eine gewagte Aussage,
denn eines darf man nicht vergessen:
Es ist alles mit Technik verbunden,
und Technik kann versagen.
In einem solchen Fall
wären auch uns die Hände gebunden.
Peter Schwitter
beobachtet den Hang Tag und Nacht.
Sobald viel Schnee gefallen ist,
drückt er einen Knopf.
Gas strömt in die Kanone.
* Anhaltendes Zischen *
* Das Zischen verebbt. *
* Langgezogene, sphärische Klänge *